you probably didn't see the javante
davis uh super mario mario
did not see that fight night and fight
of the year was it oh my god
because he gave it to javonte too he
knocked him down uh no he didn't yeah he
knocked
he knocked tank down no he did it never
happened he didn't no no oh that was the
last fight that was
that was the fight before he's never
been knocked down yes he was he was
knocked down the fight before
no he fought uh santa cruz and knocked
him out with him up yes i know that but
he got knocked down
early on in the fight i promise he did
yeah knocked down
i don't think things would have been
knocked down yeah he was knocked down
but you didn't see the supermarket but
this this so this was a hell of a this
was a rock and soccer because he
i watched the highlights i didn't watch
the whole fight which i want says knock
down here
yeah see that uh leo santa cruz yeah
he knocked him down that's javonte yeah
and then he knocked him out
oh yeah look at that [ __ ] uppercut
that other guy was sick that's
[ __ ] see if there's video of that chin
now tia fomo is he
dorantes tiffany is big enough they
they're both 35
right uh yeah yeah but not that uh
super mario barrios was uh heavier 140
140 yeah
wow i was rooting for that guy you know
super mario just deserved yeah
nothing against davis you don't realize
how good tank is
[Applause]
look at that catching them too oh god
oh hey tough
you sure tank got knocked down yeah i
don't think he's been knocked down here
i think maybe he slipped maybe he
slipped
[Applause]
man i'm a little lower remember when he
said that yeah
well i mean it autofills it says it's
you know it autofills a knockdown by
santa cruz but i can't see the videos
yeah there's i have it on it was on uh
[Music]
this is the first round
see how there's no count yeah that was a
push got you he's never been he's never
been knocked down by a punch
huh he's a [ __ ] monster yeah he's a
he's a
monster i want to see him fight tf homo
lopez though
that'd be cool what do you think of that
great fight yeah
both strong but i i got tank
just seems like he's just so what you
said that mario bar barrios
he'll still have like a pretty solid
career yeah yeah stud
he was undefeated too yeah
like that wasn't he didn't get out class
no he was up on the card
like he was he's a [ __ ] he like i
didn't really know who he was before